32 m² coin cuisine salle de bains et vue
sur cour ce sera le nouveau logement
d'une personne en situation précaire il
a rejoint la flotte de l'association
solidarités nouvelles pour le logement
et les personnes les personnes qui
viennent dans les logements et jallet
ont des profils extrêmement différents
ça peut être des personnes qui viennent
de la rue ça peut des personnes qui
dorment dans leur voiture
les personnes en situation de
suroccupation dans un logement au total
tout compris on en est à peu près à 300
euros de loyer par mois
objectif loués à des personnes en
difficulté le temps qu'elle retrouve une
situation stable ce logement et le 117e
dans les yvelines est saine elle
acquiert et rénove les futures
habitations
depuis 1997 elle est venue en aide à
près de 500 familles dans le département
nous leur donnons un tremplin pour
rebondir dans la vie les personnes les
familles il reste environ deux ans et
demi ou trois ans avec nous pour se
ressourcer pour repartir avoir un
logement savoir se projeter tant qu'on
n'a pas de logement ou qu'on a vu dans
des conditions de surpeuplement
ce n'est pas possible pour obtenir ce
nouveau studio à voisins le bretonneux
160000 euros ont été nécessaires pour
l'achat et la rénovation
un financement partagé avec la ville
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines l'état et la fondation abbé
pierre dix neuf nouveaux projets sont en
cours notamment à viroflay et à ben
je